[Music]
in our series medical price roulette
we're investigating the lack of
transparency in medical pricing
in collaboration with the journalism
company clear health costs
there is a recent study that found
nearly one in eight people with
commercial insurance who had a screening
colonoscopy
were hit with hundreds or even thousands
of dollars in unexpected charges
now there is new legislation signed by
president trump that may resolve the
problem for medicare patients
but a lot of our viewers with private
health insurance tell us they've been
stuck with such bills and simply cannot
understand why
consumer investigative correspondent
anna werner has been digging into this
anna this is so interesting good morning
good morning david you know everyone
over 50 should get a baseline screening
colonoscopy and federal guidelines say
insurance companies should pay for it so
why do we keep hearing from viewers who
say
they got stuck with the bill tammy
garissy duncan turned 50 in january and
along with her birthday came an order
from her doctor for her first screening
colonoscopy
recommended for everyone turning 50 and
supposed to be given at no
cost to patients once every 10 years
under the affordable care act
she called her insurance company to
confirm they'd pay
and what response back did you get from
blue cross blue shield
the procedure was 100 percent covered as
a screening
the facility was 100 percent covered and
the doctor
was 100 percent covered all within
network
at the clinic she says a staff member
asked if any family members had had
colonoscopies which they had
i said well my mom had a few polyps
back years ago my dad had a few polyps
after the test she says the doctor told
her everything looked good
and that was it and and when i went home
everything was well and then i started
getting the bills
and those bills for a colonoscopy that
was supposed to be covered
some six hundred twenty five dollars for
the facility over
three hundred for the doctor's services
and another three hundred twenty five
dollars for the anesthesiologist
in total over twelve hundred dollars her
insurance company refused to pay
the reason she says the clinic had
decided that because of her parents
polyps
she was now a high risk patient so then
her insurance company said
it was no longer a free screening
colonoscopy
but a diagnostic colonoscopy she'd have
to pay for
i said am i on candid camera somewhere i
don't understand this at all
it seems utterly ridiculous and i just
wonder how many people
this is happening to which is why i
contacted cbs when i heard about
you know kind of the unveiling of this
type of
problem she's not the only one who's
contacted us
we've had dozens of complaints from
people who say their free screening
colonoscopies turned into large
unexpected bills particularly if they
had pre-cancerous polyps removed
an integral part of those screenings
colorectal cancer
is the second leading cause of cancer
deaths in america
new jersey democratic congressman donald
payne jr has been trying to fix those
billing issues
his father long time congressman donald
payne senior
died of colon cancer in 2012.
unfortunately
my father would not get checked
and subsequently succumbed to the
disease
and there's no reason that he shouldn't
he shouldn't be here now
other than he wasn't screened payne
sponsored legislation to close the
billing loophole for medicare patients
so that if polyps are removed
that part of the colonoscopy will also
be paid for
people should not have to be worried if
when they go to sleep for a procedure
what the bill is going to be on the
other side his bill
passed congress last week but it doesn't
apply to private insurance patients
many of whom told us they still received
bills for colonoscopies
they thought were covered that's despite
the fact the department of health and
human services says
screening colonoscopies should be
covered for private insurance patients
even if polyps are removed is this the
way you wanted it to work
no and that patient who goes into an
office to get a screening colonoscopy
should not have to pay anything when
they wake up dr mark fendrick is a
professor of medicine and public health
at the university of michigan
who helped write that section of the aca
the fact that you're still getting
your viewers sending in these complaints
suggest
we have not implemented what i believe
is the spirit of the regulation
dr fendrick says the ultimate goal
should be for the entire screening
process to be covered for everyone
but in the meantime greasy duncan still
owes over 1200 dollars
a debt she says she has no plans to pay
i've already instructed my family
members if i were to die unfortunately
in some
tragic accident do not pay this bill
well she has an appeal pending with her
insurance company blue cross blue shield
of illinois
the company would not comment on her
individual case but told us
that doctors are the ones who code the
colonoscopies
as either a routine free screening or a
diagnostic
colonoscopy if it's a routine screening
they said
that they are free to members if they
are in network
now if you have private insurance and
you had problems with this
or any other medical pricing problem out
there we'd like to hear from you
you can email me at health costs at
cbsnews.com
tarika anna thank you so much